[Music]
demi lovato gets real about her
imperfections the 25 year old singer
took to Instagram stories late Thursday
night with a powerful message about
self-love she kicked off the series with
this video of her pulling at her stomach
along with the text stretch marks and
extra fat and yet I still love myself
next came this bootylicious clip with
the caption cellulite and yet I still
love myself and despite the fact that
demi looks pretty darn perfect to us she
added a third video explaining that her
legs look smooth thanks to the
boomerangs adding quote I have cellulite
just like the other 93% of women do what
you see on Instagram isn't always what
it seems to be let's embrace our real
selves
the songstress concluded her
motivational post with this full-length
view from the front and the caption no
thigh gap for me and yet I still love
myself I'm free to the winds back in
2015 she had this to say about thigh gap
while chatting with et if you don't have
one naturally you don't have to starve
yourself or you don't have to engage in
unhealthy behaviors it doesn't mean that
you're not beautiful
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]